[Music]
in it's all a lie news submitted by beam
boy here are 15 irrefutable reasons why
we might be living in a simulation I
feel like I'm living in GTA great like
Elon Musk nothing from you hmm you're
not I want to hear you on here
okay so Pharisee paas time irritable
reasons I'm gonna start with the like
light imma start light imma try to
refute them then okay try to refute the
15 so the Mandela effect you all heard
of it yes I brought it up before but
yeah so people remember vividly it meant
Nelson Mandela dying in the 1980s when
he really died in 2013 and they're like
how do people remember him dying in the
80s so they think that this is proof of
that
we might be like having parallel
crossovers or who's ever in charge of
the simulation is changing the past 2030
yes the bernstein bear things
yeah the Bears see exactly yes Sam yeah
cuz I am that movie that's right oh wait
was it shattered oh she said Suzanne yes
this is am saying that down the
streaming thing isn't it and it was like
I don't know it was like a Nickelodeon
show I think maybe but yeah you're
talking about what Sinbad being a genie
right yeah yeah that never happened
you remember Sinbad being a genie in a
movie no yeah yeah never happened movies
yeah that came out when I was like a
junior high early elementary school that
was never a movie for sure so do people
think Sinbad is everything like security
for like the first we was security but
he was never a genie wait he's not
hanging with mr. Cooper is he no that's
another guy he's Sinbad from the shows
do you have G no he wasn't
what no he was never a genie yeah we
talking about
I can't refute this first one okay
number two missing aliens so we have
spent billions sending probes through
outer space and like we probably should
have found evidence of extraterrestrials
I know you'd think like out of all of
the planets and stars yeah but then they
think well aliens would would likely be
far more technologically advanced than
we are they find it yeah or they figure
out how to escape from us or the
computer that we're in only has enough
RAM to simulate one planetary
civilization at a time I did this one
you can repeat this one this one the
reason why some people feel like we
can't see other aliens is so in our
visual spectrum
it goes from ultraviolet to infrared
right we can only see the things that
are above ultraviolet and the Oh below
ultraviolet and above infrared so if
other beings aren't existing in
different forms we don't have the
technology to see them and if they're
existing in the infrared form they're
not able to see us so we need only who
exists and not seeing each other in
different by mashes the same dimension
because mommy is the same things but why
do we always say that the aliens have
higher technology why can't they be the
dumb ones okay they could be that we
have like the what if aliens are like
little tiny babies that need to be
protected could be that would be cute
mm-hmm they figured out how to get here
with intergalactic space travel we have
not figured out how to get there
according they've all been here if there
are cute babies that need to be
protected they'll be our pets yeah some
people think they're living in the ocean
hmm I bet there's some sure thing that
we still don't know everything that's in
the ocean oh we have not traveled to
we're still finding new things in the
ocean I'm like nah you ever seen that
[ __ ] down and challenge your deep y'all
remember that they look like alias not
smashed that [ __ ] is crazy dude if the
ocean got drained it would be serious
they'll like like drain it and they
shows you what it looks like and it's
just like volcanic looking scary ass
rocks and [ __ ] well no and like crazy
months and the monsters
smashed and ugly with noses there was
hell on earth
it's the Dipsy you mean challenge your
daddy the Mariana Trench deep you're
gonna like this one part okay put your
science hat on so I think this one's
actually really interesting I've heard
before the electrons the electrons can't
make up their minds so in physics what
they did this experiment where electrons
are fired at a photosensitive screen
through slits in a copper plate usually
producing an interference pattern that
indicates wave-like behavior but when
the same experiment is conducted under
observation so us looking at it
electrons behave like particles not
waves and there's no interference
pattern so some people have taken this
to mean that our simulation is
conserving its resources rendering
certain things only when it knows that
we're looking at that everyday right now
so that doughnuts not a doughnut until I
look at that doughnut it's like trees
over there aren't trickles like your
friend going like this and the minute
you look at them but like I'm looking at
it so there is no yes so if a tree does
fall in the forest and no one's there to
see it it doesn't exist it didn't fall
didn't fall because it doesn't it wasn't
even a tree but what if a bird was
observing it then it would fall yeah I
hate that tree so you can't see like a
computer that doesn't have that enough
RAM so when we're looking like if we're
not yeah like going in that direction
it's like pixelated until we see it and
then it starts like appearing yeah like
in science they go nothing's impossible
it's just we haven't had the knowledge
to determine what has happened there yet
yeah so with my very basic science hat
it could be I don't know what type of
vacuum they're observing it in but it
could be every time you're coming
because everyone has ionic force so it
could be when they come the ions are
coming off their body is is determining
the waves and then they go away there's
no more waves because everyone has some
sort of magnetic force in them because
electrons and protons but that's just me
thinking out like a first grader level
where I'm sure they've already
considered these things but there's some
I guess if they study first graders I've
definitely considered this
said that people are like oh [ __ ] why
didn't we think of that
when they're closed it behaves like a
particle and then when they're away it's
like waves there's another experiment
that they did where they would shoot
protons up against this [ __ ] like
wall and then when no one was looking it
would be randomized
but then when people started to observe
it would it would shoot it directly in a
straight line I don't know nothing about
protons or Ilan's and all that kind of
stuff she's grateful she's ready for
number four how about this okay so
number four DNA that contains a computer
virus
so in 2017 yeah multidisciplinary group
of researchers at the University of
Washington proved that they could embed
malicious computer code into physical
strands of DNA their aim was to show the
computers working in gene sequencing
sequencing were vulnerable to attack but
they also inadvertently revealed that
what we perceived to be biological
reality was in fact computer code all on
that's why I say that AIDS was invented
sure wait so they they they put this
virus in and then now the human has a
virus yeah well it's not the human but
the DNA code because that's not in a
human oh it was an individual you could
just be driving just randomly out loud
to say an ad yeah thinking if they put
it in there like they have purple
mattress that's crazy [ __ ] viruses
the more the more they study DNA though
the more they believe everything has
already been predetermined mmm because
there's like so there's these things
called like your DNA it's separate into
all these things called like codons
which are like three three sets of like
DNA at a time and they kind of predict
how long your hair is gonna grow your
eye color and all that that's white
Weiner 23andme can be like you're not
good at so my DNA predicted that one day
I will smoke crack rock well they won't
they won't get you they won't they won't
they won't it's not like your freedom of
choice yeah it won't be what the more
they study them the more they realize
that there's not freedom of choice
because they think it's pretty so how
they do it is like first it's how long
are you two you're like how strongly or
maybe your your mental health is then
how prone are you to be able to
withstand or
environmental apart what if I'm an old
soul mean I'm an old soul I got freedom
of choice lease not choice yeah what but
then the choices might be between crack
and meth it's like you're gonna do drugs
anyway yeah but they're saying like your
it could be so predetermined that as
you're living it you don't even know
that you actually don't even have a
choice like it's supposed to be later
it's like oh yeah I'll prove to you it's
like it Donnie Darko where like everyone
has that strand and like you're already
predetermined to do those things
yeah like you're like you're meant to be
your predetermined to be six six which
which is gonna make you good at
basketball but because you have like
week ten mins you are gonna get injured
when you get injured now you are gonna
start this new foundation like it's
having like that type of stream of
consciousness oh it's like the Mattern
yeah everything's already pleaded right
yeah it's crazy
anyway better not work on anything then
no I mean what I said that we already
predetermined you weren't gonna work on
anything at anybody you could fill me in
bar but five climate change
how convenient our civilization is just
coincidentally set on the cusp of
environmental chaos suggesting we could
be an ancestor simulation created in
hopes that we'd show our creators how to
solve an energy crisis this theory
overlaps slightly with the aliens as
simulation quitters theory above if we
found an innovative solution to climate
crisis extraterrestrial beings might
return to crib the results but climate
hasn't always been this way it developed
into what we has only one I'm like that
stupid because during the dinosaur era
the climate was way different yeah like
we didn't have a whole zone there's
volcanoes and then they started creating
we had to create an ozone layer so like
it's the climate it's gonna has been
changing and it will keep changing yeah
it's been change fo so number six video
games that look like real life so Elon
Musk is a believer in well he's an alien
all regulation hypothesis yeah I don't
even know what is accented alien I don't
think he
okay he's uh I never heard a South
African accent like that you never heard
Bill delphine game agirl bathwater yeah
but does it sound like you are though so
basically he believes in Nick Bostrom
simulation hypothesis which posts that
if humanity can survive long enough to
create technology capable of running
convincing simulations of reality it
will create many such simulations and
therefore there will be lots of
simulated realities and only one based
reality which makes it statistically not
fathomable that we are the base reality
right ready player one yes I want it to
be like that episode of black mirror
where I die and they plug me in and I
get to just live in my fantasy world Oh
that'd be cool yeah that's nice yeah
that's good you know that you're in your
fantasy world like you know that you
died are you just completely oblivious
and that's just uni reality that's
awesome
yeah they upload your mind to para we
were talking about the black mare yeah
yeah
is it paradise specifically for you like
your paradise oh and you get to look
however you want you can like yeah I
want that you know what you know what
sucks though if we are in a simulation
man if we really are they could have
done a lot better job you think about it
right my god like 90% of us are like
losers and then 10% are like actually
killing it and life but then you don't
even know like most of them are also
depressed to [ __ ] is going on I feel
like we're all like able to create the
simulation though like we have the power
that's what like manifestations and
attackers controlling yeah you're able
to have that power but a lot of people
don't know that they have that power to
create a better reality for themselves
right Nikki Lee for president well it's
actually in here that like we all got
weak because they did the study I look
which that's true anything I wanted it
imagine I got yeah Wow you didn't really
have big imagination the law of
attraction is actually a computer code
that's true all I said was I want a fur
coat yeah okay so I don't see where it
is in here but basically they provide
you like a golden white dress then the
black and blue dress thing how everyone
saw a different thing
who's that we all see a different
reality right we like reprogramming our
eyes take a different light yeah cuz
that's just like someone going I like
peanut butter some glow that tastes like
[ __ ]
yeah okay Nikki that's just perception
what's the best thing on the list it's
not actually possible to prove we're not
living in a simulation I like to just
think so yeah so it's easier to prove
that we're living in a simulation that
to prove that we're not you know what
helps me though
it makes me feel like I don't take life
too serious
cuz I'm like yeah it's just the game
yeah don't get mad why get mad it's just
a game don't hate the player
yeah hate the game the game there's so
much death it's just the game shut up
like you have extra lives like Maura
yeah respond
that's where reincarnation came from so
agents already came up with that [ __ ]
from the beginning that's a reset button
that's an Asian thing yeah
[Music]